[Music]
well groceries are certainly a necessity
but you may have noticed a price
increase on items that you just normally
pick up and that's causing some to
question what do they really need
victoria saha joining us in the studio
with an idea of when you can start
putting more expensive items back on
your list victoria
the price increase on your favorite
meats or produce depends on where they
come from and how they are processed so
you may be seeing the issue that starts
on the top of the supply chain impacting
what's on the shelves at your local
store
whether it's fish beef chicken or eggs
there's a little bit of an increase in
prices wherever you go according to the
u.s bureau of labor statistics the price
for those items increased 10.5 percent
in the last 12 months particularly beef
which rose 17.6 percent the nevada
retail association says pre-pandemic big
cargo shipments coming from across the
globe would cost about four thousand
dollars when people started to panic by
at the beginning of the pandemic it made
that situation worse now the shipments
cost twenty five thousand dollars and a
longer wait time for them to arrive and
now you're seeing it on your receipt
this was like thirty dollars and i have
two two bags you know i have like
cooking oil and something for dinner
and a cake but i probably would have had
at least two more bags and
for for that amount for that price you
know cheryl mcgee says she has found
herself putting away a lot of items that
she would normally get because of the
price increase like kitty litter
the nevada retail association tells me
we could see this issue continue for a
few more months tonight at five we will
have some tips to help you and your
family stay on budget when grocery
shopping denise okay i would still need
the kitty litter no matter how much it
cost so we wanted to hear from you we
asked on twitter have you noticed
perhaps your grocery bill going up look
at this overwhelming nearly 90 percent
of you said yes they certainly have seen
an increase at the grocery store here